the writer HG Wells who first imagined
time machines and alien invasions had a
nightmare of a future world where atoms
were weaponized in his book called the
world set free written in 1913 he coined
the phrase atomic bombs and loosed them
on helpless civilian populations
he set his vision of a nuclear war
between England and Germany in the
impossibly distant future of the 1950s
[Music]
[Music]
in 1933 the Hungarian physicist Leo
Szilard was contemplating becoming a
biologist Dillard are you quite all
right in there
he read wells his novel and it started
him thinking
[Music]
Dillard knew that atoms are made of
protons and neutrons on the inside and a
skittering veil of electrons on the
outside suddenly while waiting for the
light to change at this intersection in
London he was struck by the thought if
he could find a sufficiently large
amount of an element that would admit to
neutrons when it absorbed one it would
sustain a nuclear chain reaction two
would produce four four would produce
eight and so forth until the enormous
amounts of energy in the nucleus itself
could be liberated not a chemical
reaction but a nuclear one
[Music]
this was the moment our world changed
Leos allured also knew the power of
Exponential's and as a neutron chain
reaction could be triggered down there
in the world of the atom's nucleus and
something like Wells as imaginary atomic
bomb might be possible he shuddered at
the thought of this destructive
capability it was just the latest
development on a continuum of violence
that began long long before fifty
thousand years ago all humans were
roving bands of hunter-gatherers they
communicated over limited areas by
calling to one another that is at the
speed of sound around 750 miles per hour
but over longer distances they could
communicate only as fast as they could
run around 12,000 years ago about the
same time as the invention of
Agriculture they developed the power to
kill at a longer distance the kill
radius expanded to the arc of an arrow
launched by a bow and they could kill
one person with a single arrow our
ancestors were not particularly more
like because there's so few people and
so much room back then that moving on
was preferable to armed conflict their
weapons were used almost entirely for
hunting their identification horizon was
likely small only with the other members
of their band of fifty or hundred people
but their time horizon took a giant leap
they worked long and hard planting crops
in the here and now so several months
later they could harvest them they
postpone present gratification for later
advantage they began to plan for the
future
[Music]
you